[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
here we are again for another one of our
live conversations and these are live
conversations i always
am amused when i see in the chat people
say is this live is this live yeah it's
live
if you're watching it live right if
you're not watching it live it's not
live and i don't know maybe just to uh
establish that fact it's always good to
uh
respond in real time there is one
question here from
someone in fiji i don't know where the
the question runt
question went i should say had to do
with black holes and string theory
uh if you want to ask that question
again our
participant from fiji i'll try to
look at it but
the main event today as you all know
is a conversation with lenny suskind
who's really one of the great
theoretical physicists of our time so
it's an exciting
guest to have on the program as many of
you know lenny has
had profound impact in string theory
black hole physics quantum mechanics
elementary particle physics i mean it's
um
quite a lot quite a lot of
accomplishments and we'll obviously only
be talking about
part of those insights but i think we'll
likely
skew heavily on black holes
you know as you reach the end of a year
there's a tendency to
think back on the good things the bad
things summarize you know
all these best of lists worst of lists
things of that sort if i was going to
focus upon
the best of physics or let's say
theoretical physics
in 2020 even perhaps even earlier
black holes would be near the top
perhaps at the top you know we've had um
a great run and it is continuing onward
and we're going to
discuss today some of the puzzles that
remain
but some of the deep puzzles of the past
that today just are not as puzzling any
longer it's not that everything has been
resolved
it's rare that deep puzzles just get
fully
thoroughly resolved but
there are many things that were
very unclear even as
early as uh 15 20 25 years ago that now
have really been unraveled and lenny and
a bunch of other
folks that will no doubt make reference
to critical
to making that happen so lenny will join
us at about
1 30 or so i'll do a little bit of q a
maybe just a couple questions if there's
something to get us going
uh and then i'll maybe give a i don't
know a little background to the
conversation that we're going to have
with lenny so here's a question from
captain vyom how are dark energy
and dark matter related captain vyam
asks and i like questions like that
because the answer is short
basically i don't know and nobody does
know how these dark
things are related they may be related
they may not be related remember dark
matter is this idea
of matter that is out there we believe
in space and we come to that conclusion
because
when we take account of the gravity that
can be
exerted by the matter that's not dark
which means matter that we can see gives
off light reflects light matter of that
sort
the amount of gravity that such matter
can exert just
is not enough to account for the motions
that we see
through astrophysical measurements
astrophysical data right i mean the
analogy that
i'd like to use i think it's a pretty
good one if you have a
a bicycle wheel that's wet as it spins
you know that the water droplets
fly off as the wheel turns
similarly in galaxies that are spinning
if they're spinning at a sufficiently
fast rate
stars should be flung outward
and we see galaxies for which the stars
should be flung outwards but they're not
which must mean there's something else
out there that's holding those stars
inside of those galaxies the belief is
that there's additional matter beyond
the matter that we can see with our
telescopes and that dark matter is
responsible for the gravitational pull
that's keeping those stars from flying
outwards
like the water droplets good that's dark
matter i should say there's a lot of
dark matter we think
when you do these calculations there's
on the order of four or five times
as much dark matter as there is ordinary
matter you know the stuff that we're
made of
dark energy is a different beast dark
energy
the most convincing evidence for it are
these observations that we've discussed
in this series from time to time of the
accelerated expansion of space
space is not only getting larger over
time that was a shock
right that was the shock that initially
was
really confirmed through the
observations of edwin
hubble but not only is universe getting
bigger it's getting bigger
at an accelerated clip so the expansion
is speeding
up how can expansion speed up right
galaxies they pull on each other
with the force of gravity force of
gravity we usually think of as pulling
things inward
but yet something's pushing outward and
the remarkable thing is that in albert
einstein's general theory of relativity
gravity can actually be repulsive it can
push outward
not if the source of that gravity is a
clump like
a star a clump like a galaxy a clump
like a planet rather if there's a
diffuse energy
that is spread uniformly throughout a
region of space
then under modest assumptions it will
give rise to
a repulsive push an outward push that
can drive
the expansion of space to accelerate and
because this energy does not itself give
off light we call it dark energy
so there are the two dark things dark
matter dark energy and again i gave you
the amount of dark matter
dark energies in terms of the energy
mass
budget of the universe is even more
substantial
on the order of 70 percent of the mass
energy of the universe is this dark
energy
so that are these two components now are
they related
many people have written down theories
which suggest that they are
none of these have really gained the
consensus
of the scientific community as yet but
who knows
you know they both have dark in their
name is that the end of the connection
or is it deeper i don't know all right
anyway so that's uh
a good question to get us going here
mark kennedy also has how much do you
miss mama joys i
i don't know what that means but it does
ring a bell
somewhere deep in my childhood or
something
i know what you're talking about mark i
think
or maybe not maybe it's something that i
don't want to remember i don't know but
anyway i can't answer the question
i don't remember exactly what it means a
quick one more before we head on to a
little bit of background
uh physics forever asks what are strings
made of we'll talk a little bit about
string theory here
today no doubt lenny suskind
founding father pioneer of string theory
i'm sure
it will come up in our conversation and
look when you think about
any proposal for what stuff is made of
and you think back on the history of
ideas any proposal for what stuff is
made of seem to ultimately
have finer stuff inside of it right
molecules made of atoms atoms yeah
nucleus with electrons in these
fuzzy quantum orbits the nucleus has
smaller things protons and neutrons
inside protons and neutrons
smaller things called quarks if string
theory is right
big f really we'll talk about that
then inside of these particles are these
little vibrating filaments
these string-like filaments of energy so
if that's the correct picture natural
question is is that the end of the line
have we reached the smallest
of the matroyska dolls if i'm
pronouncing that correctly no doubt
somebody will correct me you know the
russian dolls
each has a smaller doll inside of it is
it that strings have some smaller entity
inside of them too
i don't know could be string to the end
of the line
could be that there are
finer ingredients in some sense strength
even suggests that possibility with
things called d0 particles at some level
maybe we'll talk about that a little bit
too but
it's a natural question and one that
uh we don't fully uh know the answer to
that's two questions that we don't know
for the answer to
maybe there's a question here that i can
actually answer that would be that would
be nice
give me a little uh boost to keep on
going um um
yeah another question about string
theory let me just find uh
uh tishia patel can we describe the
fabric of spacetime is made of particles
i seem to be drawn to the questions that
i can't answer here this uh this
afternoon
and in in a sense yes so
in the quantum mechanical framework the
forces that influence how
things move the electromagnetic force
and nuclear forces
they're all part of the standard model
of particle physics which envisions that
those forces are indeed
communicated by a particle
right for the electromagnetic force
photons nuclear forces w and z bosons
and so forth
now gravity is a force of nature as well
einstein tells us the gravity is
associated with space-time
the geometrical structure of space-time
determines the gravitational influence
that a body moving through that region
of space time will experience
now if you believe as most of us do that
quantum mechanics and general relativity
have got to come together
then the paradigm of a force being
communicated by a particle
will spill over to the gravitational
influence as well and that gives rise to
this notion of gravitons
no one has ever seen a graviton we're
not surprised by that it's the
smallest packet of the weakest of
nature's forces so it's not
as though we have expected to see it
lighting up our detectors and it hasn't
so not a mystery
but if this idea is true then you can
actually think of the fabric of space
which is the medium of gravity as being
a whole huge collection of gravitons
that are arranged in a coherent pattern
that manifests on large scales
as the geometry of space-time but on
small scales would have this distinct
particulate quantum mechanical
description so
i can't say the answer is absolutely yes
but certainly there is a
natural intellectual pathway that would
take us
to that picture all right good let's um
i'm happy to again answer questions as
they come through and as
in the conversation with lenny i'll try
to look and sometimes it's hard some of
you have asked why
for instance in the conversation with
roger penrose that we had last week
why i didn't turn to some of the
questions that you ask and honestly i
just get so carried away in the
conversation sometimes with the person
i'm speaking with that breaking away to
try to scan through the list of
questions can be difficult
we do have somebody looking at those
questions right now so if you ask
something that's really
on point highly relevant to wherever we
are
in the conversation with lenny i'm more
than happy to try to bring
your questions into the conversation so
um i'm
absolutely for the open to that without
a doubt all right so a little bit of
background
lenny will join us about 10 12 minutes
so look we're all now familiar that
black holes are an observationally
confirmed
quality of reality right the event
horizon telescope we have a little black
hole image from them
of course we can bring it up on the
screen where
you know in the most direct way you see
a black hole right i mean a black hole
is nothing but a region in space where
light can't get
out and the event horizon telescope
imagery
is one that makes that you know the most
straightforward
confirmation of that idea so i
see it on my screen here hope you guys
see it on yours
which would be good i think you do now
black holes really came out of the
mathematics of carl schwarzschild way
back
in 1916 1917
or so and it's an idea that
you know is interesting exciting but it
kind of became a bit of a backwater of
physics for
a long period of time it's really john
wheeler
who i think we have a little image of
john wheeler nice
to sort of see it was john wheeler who
brought
the study of einstein's general
relativity and
the puzzles of black hole physics he
really brought that into
mainstream physics research so
he's really responsible for that and and
john wheeler had a
very particular puzzle about black holes
that we're going to be talking about
with lenny suskind
wheeler worried he was a very genteel
man he worried that if he was drinking a
hot cup of tea
okay there's a lot of entropy in
a hot cup of tea the disorder of the
water molecules bouncing
to and fro in that cup of tea he worried
that if there was a nearby black hole he
could take his cup of tea
with the hot water with all that entropy
and just throw it into the black hole
and then he worried that if the
cup of tea and the entropy went to black
hole since black holes don't let
anything to come out
the entropy in some sense would be gone
and he worried about that
because the second law of thermodynamics
tells us that entropy should always go
up
and wheeler said i seem to be able to
use a black hole to thwart
the second law of thermodynamics i just
keep
dumping entropy into a black hole it's
gone and in that way
entropy in the rest of the universe the
observable universe perhaps is the only
part that
we observers ever have access to would
go down so he mentioned this puzzle
to his student student named jacob
beckenstein a brilliant student
and and beckenstein came up with
an idea to resolve
this puzzle and the idea is
that black holes do have
entropy black holes do have entropy
they're not the simple pristine objects
as indicated by einstein's general
theory of relativity where when you look
at the mathematics from carl
schwarzschild back in 1916
you find in some sense that black holes
seem to be the simplest of all
things in the universe you specify their
mass
or also their charge and their angular
momentum just give a couple numbers
and you completely nail down what that
black hole is
whereas for us to nail down most things
in the world around us you got to get a
lot more
information than just three numbers
to nail it down right if you wanted to
describe
the exact physical state of my body
good luck so many particles and so many
interactions
that to write down the quantum
mechanical wave function
you know the exact quantum description
of my body would be pretty
pretty tough in the exact classical
description would be pretty tough
for black hole the exact classical
description was quite simple and that
led people to wonder how in the world a
black hole could have entropy entropy
you need
something to carry the disorder
something that is able to
be affected by say
john wheeler's cup of hot tea falling
inside but beckensen had a beautiful
argument
and the argument a little too
long to go through it completely right
now but the upshot of the argument was
that if you know the area of the event
horizon of a black hole
then you know the entropy of the black
hole he basically says take the
area of the event horizon of black hole
break it up into little plank size
squares what's the plank length remember
that's this little tiny length at which
gravity
quantum mechanics really come together
10 to the minus 33 centimeters is the
plank length so the plank length squared
a little square
whose size or the plank length would be
about 10 to the minus 66 centimeters
squared a really tiny
area but take the entire
surface area of the event riser black
will break it up into these little
plank-sized squares
and that number of those plaquettes
plank plaquettes is the entropy of a
black hole
now stephen hawking heard about this
and thought it was nonsense didn't think
that
black holes could have entropy
and set out to disprove beckenstein's
ideas that was his goal and
remarkably stephen hawking
wound up confirming beckenstein's ideas
and going even further
he not only showed that black holes do
have entropy surprise number one
but then he said look in a very
mathematical way that i'll just say in
words you said look any object that has
entropy it also
has heat remember heat entropy really
wetted together and any object
that has heat has a temperature
and therefore black holes in some sense
should glow
with a particular temperature in fact
you give an exact formula for what the
temperature
of a black hole would be don't need the
details but it goes like one over the
mass of the black hole
so now black holes are not even these
simple pristine objects as einstein's
math seemed to initially suggest but now
they carried entropy their surface area
they carried
temperature and because they carry
temperature they glow
which means that things in some sense
are
coming out of a block on a very precise
way
they're not coming out from deep inside
the black hole they're really coming
right from the edge the event horizon of
the black hole
but this now raised the puzzle and the
puzzle is okay look
if the black hole is glowing if it's
radiating so-called hawking radiation
in fact we have a little hawking
radiation image maybe we can jump
to that just to show up what it would
look like to have a black hole hawking
and you see these uh particles of
radiation streaming out from the
event horizon of a black hole so here's
the puzzle
as this black hole continues to radiate
and as it gets smaller its mass goes
down i said the temperature goes like
one over the mass so the intensity of
the radiation goes up
and up and up over time here's the deep
question
does that radiation have
any memory any imprint of the detailed
objects that fell
in to the black hole to construct
the black hole now if you throw in
your your iphone your computer whatever
into the black hole a lot of information
in there
does the information that goes in come
out
with this radiation that is the big
puzzle and stephen hawking famously said
that the radiation
does not carry an imprint
of the information of what fell in
and lenny suskind and gerard
tuft and others but they were really the
pioneers of these ideas
they would not accept
stephen hawking's declaration and
we're going to talk about what
ultimately lenny suskind describes as
the black hole war
a war that i think he would agree that
he won he and his colleagues have won
and we'll go through that as well as the
next
stage in the battles that are now being
waged today
and i see that lenny has joined us
so let me just give a quick introduction
many of you know lenny of course
through his wonderful popular books the
black hole war
the cosmic landscape he is the felix
block professor of theoretical physics
at stanford university
and since 2009 he's been director of the
stanford institute for theoretical
physics
he has made tremendous contributions to
physics across the board string theory
black holes quantum mechanics elementary
particle physics
so it's a it's a pleasure to welcome
lenny to the discussion lenny how are
you doing good
how are you brian i'm doing pretty well
where are you right now in uh
at stanford at stanford no i haven't
been at stanford in
stanford university since early march
yeah yeah but i'm a mile and a half away
in my house
and you've been teaching me like like
all of us you've been doing the zoom
teaching
yeah yeah uh this quarter i wasn't
teaching
next quarter i'll be teaching and um
yeah but i've been doing a lot of
lecturing a lot of communicating with
the public and so forth
and my physics colleagues zoom
is a wonderful thing yeah you try to
imagine what it would be like if there
weren't these tools i mean if this would
have happened ten years ago uh yeah
it would have been uh quite an impact
well i probably would have um
sat down at my desk with a piece of
paper in front of me and written some
good papers
yeah as it is i had so much contact and
so much fun uh with my
uh with my colleagues uh physics has
done a marvelous job of keeping us all
from
actually working and uh so
yeah who knows now remember at the
beginning of this there was a lot of
chatter among
uh physicists that were now in the
position of
isaac newton black death and
if newton would have had zoom maybe we
would come up with the universal law of
gravity
yeah yeah i think i think we'd still be
in uh
thinking that gravity was due what did
they think the gravity was due to then
friction i don't know i don't know uh
action at a distance or something
no that was newton yeah
[Music]
yeah oh you mean prior to newton yeah
yeah yeah yeah
uh yeah i don't know if the things one
things want to fall
right oh that's right aristotle i guess
very uh anthropomorphic view of right so
so if zoom if zoom exit existed and when
was it 1687 or something around then
yeah we'd still be thinking that things
want to fall
yeah okay hey i wanted to ask you
uh i heard just because of where i am at
the moment
um i am about 15 minutes from a place
called
the beaver kill is it true that you you
are wow what are you doing up there
so we have a uh just a house up here in
the middle of nowhere so since march we
kind of disappeared up here and somebody
mentioned to me that you spent time as a
kid
in in oh yes when i was like just not
just as a kid as a young man
too my father was a fly fisherman he
taught me how to fly fish the beaver
kill
is one of the great eastern um
trout fly fishing uh rivers
and yes i spent a lot of time on it yeah
ever come uh i mean in recent times do
you uh
ever come back these ways no i i would
love to but
just too far away so where is your where
is your place livingston manor
no we are about 45 minutes from
livingston manner we go the other
direction
so if you head out um toward andy's
we're near andy's new york i don't know
if you know that little town
i don't know where it is yeah most
people who stop at beaver cold don't
know what happens further down the road
it's like north of 96th street in
manhattan nobody knows about it
exactly right so we're on the other side
of the tracks in some sense but uh
so i was a very urban kid extremely
urban but still
uh you know several times of summer we
go up to the beaver kill
get in the car drive up there take our
flies
uh fly rods and fish in the river
yeah and your dad was a was a plumber he
was a plumber
yeah and he expected you to go in the
family business
you really did yeah and and you did did
you do
so you did some plumbing right yeah for
10 years maybe from about the age of
12 or 13 until i was 22
and went away to graduate school and and
so
what did your dad think about your i
can't say that i liked it that was not a
very good plumber
and but did your dad i mean did you
support your move from
the family yeah well that's a story i've
told
many many times but yes you did in the
end
in the end he was uh really troubled
when
i was already married i had children or
one child
and uh i had decided i wanted to be a
physicist
i went to see my father and told him and
he was pretty upset
in fact he didn't know what a physicist
was he he had a fifth grade education he
did not know what a physicist was
and he made the mistake of thinking that
i said pharmacist
no no you're not going to work in a drug
store
but i said the one word which was
guaranteed to i
not intentionally i said like einstein
and you know at that time especially
among jews in new york
einstein was a magic word yeah he said
are you any good at this
i said well i hope so i think so right
and
uh yeah that was it that was it he said
okay you're gonna be einstein and that
was it
and i failed him i failed everything
yeah you i think you've done quite well
for yourself young man
um so i want to get into some of the um
you know the scientific
ideas contributions that you that's what
i'm here for
but can we spend a moment on on other
things for a moment that
many in the audience will know you from
namely the books
the wonderful books written you know
because i remember
i don't remember exactly what it was but
i think it was in amsterdam
you told me that you were writing i must
have been
the cosmic landscape i think it was your
first book
and and you mentioned to me what a blast
you were having
you know writing this stuff so so look
it's a great service to the public but
presumably this is something that you
deeply enjoy doing and maybe come
through in the right i did i got so into
it i got so
into it that um you know i would
i took a leave of absence to write the
book
i think for pretty much a whole year and
i had some sabbatical leave
leave for absence and i would get up you
know eight o'clock in the morning
sit down at the computer and by five
o'clock in the afternoon my wife would
have to drag me away
it was really fun uh i really enjoyed
writing about physics
but it turned out that i also really
enjoy writing about people
well of course i enjoy writing about
myself we all do
no i don't know if we all do but right
well you but it's interesting that you
say that
about people because the one
i don't know if you remember this event
i think i was speaking like to the queen
or something like that
at holland but we only spoke for a woman
and and
and and i wanted to like there was one
piece of advice i wanted to give you one
right you didn't need it obviously but
the one thing that i would have said was
when i wrote my first draft of my first
book elegant universe i left out all the
people
i was afraid that like somebody would
get mad that i didn't give them the
right
credit and so i said look let me just
leave everybody out they'll like make it
simple and the book was
i went back and put all the people
back in and and then when i put the
people in
it came to life it came to life yeah you
know yeah well i enjoyed writing about
the people from the beginning
i've always enjoyed the history of
physics i enjoyed uh
learning how the people how the people
thought
i've always been very very interested in
how
particularly physicists but more
generally how people think about things
how their minds work and uh and
um so i i found it very very interesting
to go back over
my oh not not my whole life but uh
the uh the episodes that took place and
trying to figure out you know what was
going on in people's minds
and uh then when i came to write about
it i just it was just natural for me to
to take it from that point of view yeah
i mean you write very much like
you speak i try to do that too i mean
are you basically
letting it just flow as if it's a
conversation when you're writing is that
the process yeah it's interesting
my first time around when i write
whatever i write
i write it in the language that we all
learned to write in when we became
physicists the dull boring
really technical uh way of writing
and then i have to go back over it and
eventually it starts to flow
eventually but each time i start to
write each new subject
the book had what 12 chapters i don't
remember
and each chapter started the same way it
sounded
like the sort of things we write when we
write
physics papers and then looking at it
you know i'm not sure if i write well
but i do read well
and i do have some sense of when things
work right i look at boy that doesn't
work that really doesn't work
and uh so i start thinking about how to
explain things better and after a while
that technical jargon stuff sort of
forms a backbone for
writing but then it starts to flow and
it becomes a sort of natural language
so the first time around not natural
language second time around
yes it becomes i i also oh the other
thing i do
is i read what i wrote out loud yeah
that's very helpful
yeah i read it out loud and see what did
that sound like
yeah no it's very similar to what i
would i do as well and it's interesting
you mentioned
the way we're all trained to write as
physicists because i was reading
not that long ago the original davis and
germa
and in that paper they described
in a different way the accident in the
laboratory
when they were doing you know electron
scattering off of nickel
crystal and they describe what happened
they turned up the intensity too high
they ruptured
the vacuum chamber they had to clean off
the nickel crystal
by doing that they changed the
scattering centers and in that way
led to data that confirmed what we now
call the double slit experiment
but today if people had that experience
they wouldn't write about
the accident they would just write about
the result
right and and so we have taken some of
the human side out of things
very much so yeah yeah i find that sad
um yeah i don't know what to do about it
so so what do you think that we do as
physicists
i mean do you think that we are
revealing
truths realities or just making models
of
of of the world oh gee you know that's
yeah that's a tough question
it's as tough as any question i can
think about about the
question of what is reality does reality
exist are we finding it
or are we just making models of it and
um
i think my tendency is to say put that
aside
and let's just uh let's just go with our
curiosity
i'm curious about how this works let me
try to figure it out
um it's a pretense but i like to pretend
that i'm more of a car mechanic than a
philosopher
trying to not a car mechanic but
somebody trying to figure out how the
car works
uh that's of course a little bit
pretentious i'm not a car mechanic but
um but i i do like to
think of myself as somebody trying to
figure out how a piece of machinery
works
a piece of quantum machinery so it's not
like a car
and just uh
try to understand how its parts work how
they fit together what's going on how
does quantum mechanics fit together with
gravity
and not worry too much about
these very heavyweight questions that i
know that i'm not going to be able to
answer
yeah but i mean it's totally remarkable
that we can even
even do that right i mean einstein
famously said the most incomprehensible
thing about the universe is that it's
comprehensible now there's two ways of
interpreting that
one is the fact that the universe has
these patterns but two that we can
figure them out
yes i just i i just gave a lecture i
give the lecture simon's institute i
think
and uh i began by pointing out
exactly that that somehow evolution
created a species just
one step above the monkeys that uh can
not only
ask questions about how nature works but
follow the thoughts and figure out how
nature works
and that is a very very remarkable fact
yeah that i i don't know anybody
understand that does anybody understand
how evolution
gave us the ability to figure out
quantum mechanics
i don't know but doesn't it it's very
hard to imagine you know natural
selection
would tend to select those things that
help for survival and those of our
forebears who sat down and thought about
quantum mechanics on the african savanna
are the ones that probably got eaten
because they didn't have a lion that was
going up you know tripped over their
feet that's right
yeah totally um you know there's this
there's also this moment
if you remember but in in the the the
television adaptation of the elegant
universe that you were in
um there was a moment in the beginning
where i'm lecturing to a dog you don't
know that at first i'm just doing
you know einstein's equations on the
blackboard and there's some student
who's not getting it in the camera pans
and it's a dog and the point there was
there are many intelligent creatures on
this planet that don't have this ability
as far as we know
you know to figure out how to figure out
these things so what is it that allowed
us
us to do that and so yes it is did you
ever did you ever
did you ever read kafka's investigations
of a dog
i have not i don't think i have tell me
well kafka was making phonophysicists
basically
and uh he invented a dog that
became curious and tried to figure out
how the world worked
and among other things he tried to
figure out where food comes from
he didn't understand why uh how food
appeared in his
dish he didn't understand how it circled
from above and came down and he made all
kinds of theories about the
[Music]
so it's very funny it's very funny i
think it was i think it was making fun
of physicists
yeah no it sounds uh it sounds
kafka-esque and it's
very very much that's right so before we
move on to actual science there's only
one other thing i wanted to mention too
uh in in of the black hole war
there is an unusual and wonderful
chapter
where you describe a very personal
stretch of time when you were utterly
obsessed with stephen hawking utterly
obsessed with wanting him to
see the light and almost like in your
words
you know ahab going after the the white
whale you were like tracking him down
no when you were right i mean it's an
exciting chapter to read but when you
were writing that
and i sometimes go through this too was
there a question of
am i revealing too much of myself is
this
you know you know i no i i don't i was
having fun
yeah i was having fun writing sort of
enjoying uh
enjoying reminiscing and thinking about
my experiences
i i wasn't i wasn't that kind i wasn't
worried about that no
yeah it certainly shows how physics is
not
a nine to five undertaking right i mean
it's
uh it's uh it's all it's all
encompassing
when you're working with these kinds of
questions
all right so yes it's it's a combination
of 24 hours a day
and maybe three days out of the year
three days out of the year something
happens the other uh
the other 24 hours a day uh sort of
frustration banging your head on the
wall
well it's good for students to hear that
i i mean as you know
i mean the number of graduate students
that i've encountered who
just wonder when the big breakthrough is
going to happen you know when
and and and it's rare you know it's just
unfortunately rare you know um so i
wanted to talk a bit
about some of the breakthroughs of
uh in some sense the last 25-30 years
but we'll
hopefully get toward toward the end i
mean the things that involved here
general relativity quantum mechanics
thermodynamics statistical mechanics
black holes entropy entanglement
you know worm i mean it's just an ending
list of of
and now and now computer science is
coming from your time
totally so can we just do a brief run
through
of the general relativity side of things
the puzzles
that um were apparent to you in gerard a
tough not apparent
to many others and then where things
stand today
on all that so you know i made mention
before you came on to john wheeler and
his teacup
worrying about what would happen if he
threw his teacup into a black hole where
the
where would the entropy go when did you
start
worrying about questions like that
well okay so i didn't learn really much
about it until
oh roughly 1980 1981
which was seven or eight years after
beckenstein had
made his great breakthrough and
discovered that black holes have entropy
before that i was obsessed like most of
my generation of theoretical physicists
with problems of elementary particle
physics
i it was 1980 or 81 i can't remember
exactly it was at a small
conference that took place in the
mansion of a rich man in uh
in san francisco werner earhart as a
matter of fact
some of you may know his name um and uh
yes guy or something right right right
he was also a physics groupie and um
anyway stephen was there gerard the tuft
was there
and a bunch of other people that i can't
remember right now
but uh i think i don't know whether
gerard knew very much about what stephen
was talking about
beforehand but stephen got up and said
black holes lose information that what
goes into a black hole cannot come out
uh of course in practice that's sort of
true
but in some very deep fundamental sense
he said there was a contradiction
with uh a basic rule of physics and the
basic rule of physics is nothing
really ever gets lost information never
gets lost it's called unitarity in
quantum mechanics
but it says that uh that what goes in
comes out
even if it may come out in a horribly
scrambled form that's extremely
un uh extremely difficult to disentangle
anything that goes into a black hole has
to come out anything that goes into
anything into a fire
into a furnace whatever has to come out
even if it comes out in the form which
is
very difficult to decipher okay
steven said black holes are not like
that black holes are different what goes
in
in order for it to come out it would
have to exceed the speed of light and we
can't exceed the speed of light and so
black holes are fundamentally different
than anything else in nature
and in fact they must break the rules
of basic quantum mechanics um
that just felt wrong i realized the
depth of the question the question was
clearly very very deep
and very very important i can't even
explain
why it sounded wrong so much of what i
knew about physics
was ultimately based on a rule of
physics
you can call it what com what goes in
has to come out you can call it
unitarity
you can call it reversibility any number
of different terms for it
um and everything i knew about physics
rested on that linchpin that uh of
unitary let's call it
it had to be wrong stephen was giving up
quantum mechanics prematurely
not only prematurely wrongly he had
asked an extremely deep question
and in my mind and in the tufts come to
too easy and answer
just the quantum mechanics was wrong
i just wanted do you think that's
because stephen was coming at the world
from a general relativity perspective
yeah yeah i think i think so but
i think that was part of it um but he
certainly had a very deep understanding
of quantum mechanics he could not have
done what he did
had he not have that that deep
understanding of quantum mechanics
i think maybe there was also an element
that he got so excited
by his own uh revelation that quantum
mechanics had to be wrong
that he found it psychologically hard to
let go of it i think but i
i knew stephen it was hard to know
stephen
i know for certain that he admired me
i certainly admired him um to get into
his head was
so difficult for the just because of the
physical
barrier the physical barrier of him not
being able to
uh to communicate uh so
i can't really say what was in his head
but he insisted
uh as rod and i insisted that he was
wrong
and uh from that time forward
i think i felt that that was the biggest
problem that i could address the rest of
my uh
whatever abilities i had to try to
uncover what was going on there but
strangely you've also noted that
not many other people elevated issue the
way you did
yeah the that's right the general
relativity community for the most part
just thought that stephen was right he
said okay information is lost in uh
in black holes that sort of stunned me
but i guess maybe uh well
the the particular component of the
general relativity people
were people who did know quantum
mechanics and did appreciate quantum
mechanics
uh so
it wasn't that for a lack of
appreciation of quantum mechanics but
somehow
they just um uh took it
as given that what goes into a black
hole can't come out
and that was the end of the story for
them uh
the particle physics community which was
much more
centered on the rules of quantum
mechanics the rule
that i just called unitarity was an
essential component
of of particle physics
they tended not to be too interested in
gravity
the reason was i think feynman said it
he said that gravity is so remote
so remote in the sense of being the
gravity quantum mechanics of gravity
here is so remote that it'll be 500
years before we'll be able to learn
anything about it
and so the particle physics community
had other fish to fry
they had the standard model they had
quantum chromodynamics
uh and so forth and so they just you
know they said don't bother us with this
gravity crap
right it's uh there was very very few
people
who uh really got terribly excited
by this very deep observation of stevens
and so i sort of felt in the wilderness
for i'm not sure
how long maybe a period of 10 years were
these ideas pretty much percolating the
back of your mind because you were also
engaging with all these other
areas too that were more in the
forefront at that time yeah
yeah no it was not in the back of my
mind it was in the front of my mind but
yes that was uh very troubling
and and and so uh were you in gerard
sort of comrades in arms on this kind of
thing or were you both going your own
ways and communicating now and then
gerard and i are friends we've always
we've been friends for a long time
uh you know he's a bit of a contrarian
and
he's a dutchman which makes him a little
bit bristly
my description of my relationship with
him was so very often i would consider
i would say to sarah zoron i completely
agree with you
and his answer would be yes but i
completely disagree with you
so but we do yeah we uh we certainly
communicated quite a bit and um
for me for my part i felt
uh comforted by the fact that gerard had
the same views that i did
i considered him a very great physicist
and i
i saw him as being extremely deep and
the fact that he
had pretty much the same views that i
had was it was uh
comforting and and so the picture that
you guys
began to develop which now
has been elevated to a principle
holographic principle
can you just tell us a little bit about
what led to this
perspective that that the information
somehow
exists on the surface of a black hole
when an entity falls in
yeah um right i was
good it is literally true i've been
thinking
a lot about the information falling into
a black hole
and to me the big puzzle was it seemed
like information had to be in two places
at the same time
if you were to if you were to take the
view that gerard and i did
that information that falls into a black
hole
is ultimately radiated back out
in the hawking radiation and at the same
time that information
can fall through the horizon of the
black hole
then it seemed like there was something
going on that said that information
somehow can be in two places at the same
time
or if not in two places at the same time
very much
like quantum complementarity that either
you look at it one way
or the other way but you don't try to
you don't try to look at it both ways
uh so somebody falling into a black hole
sees the information going into the
black hole somebody outside
sees it outside something funny going on
about
the localization of information it was
literally true um i've told the story
a number of times i think i even wrote
about it and people tend to disbelieve
me they think that i'm
sort of making up a little story it was
not a story i was walking
uh in stanford also stanford at that
time
there was a small science small physics
display uh we called it a museum
and and the display there was a hologram
there was a hologram of a very very
pretty girl and the
there was the the picture of the of the
girl was surrounded by a film
and i knew what a hologram was but it
just hit me
there's an example of information
that's being stored in the film strictly
speaking it's being stored in the
two-dimensional film
and if you looked at the film you would
just see a bun a little carefully
through a microscope
all you would see would be random
markings with no particular structure
that you would recognize
and if you did the right thing with that
film mainly shine light on it but it
doesn't
do the right translation dictionary you
would reconstruct a full
three-dimensional object in the interior
of this space which was surrounded by
the film
it was literally true i looked at that
and i said could it be
that in some quantum mechanical way
the surface of a black hole the horizon
of the black hole is functioning as a
kind of hologram
where information can be thought of as
being stored
on the boundary on the horizon itself
being like
the film itself and at the same time
a translation dictionary would allow you
to think of that as information that
fell
into the black hole
that that was sometime around 1993
gerard was thinking i guess very very
something very very similar
and uh he published he published the
idea
i uh i didn't even i didn't even know
that he had published it i found out
after writing my own paper on it
somebody uh
somebody told me that he had written a
paper
i couldn't find the paper but i spoke to
gerard
and he told me what he was thinking it
was very similar and so i just
attributed it to him
the basic idea but holographic
way of thinking about it was your image
of
how to explain what the black hole was
doing then presumably yeah
yeah but there was a generalization of
it which i think we both thought about
but gerard really really expressed it
very clearly
that it wasn't just a black hole if you
take a region of space
no matter what is in it whether it's a
black hole or anything else
you should be simply because a black
hole
carries more information than anything
else
that a region of space cannot have more
information
in it than that that which can be
described
as being on the surface of the region of
space rather than in the volume
and so it became more than just the
theory of black holes it became a theory
that if you like
of a piece of the universe if you take a
piece of the universe it should be
possible to describe it
in terms of degrees of freedom
mathematical structures
that in some sense live on the surface
of the region of space
so right i mean that's just shocking it
looks very shocking
okay i i called my paper the world as a
hologram
um i don't remember what azeroth called
his
yes it was not only shocking it was also
thought to be a big crackpot
yeah um not too bad uh
yes when i would talk about it i got the
feeling
sort of mildly amused that uh people had
thought
that both gerard and i had lost our
marbles
we were once good physicists but here we
were um
a little bit crazy but it might be good
to explain to people
how nuts i mean we're used to physics
being you know things take place
in the volume of space you can tinker
with it you can tinker with there but
you're in some sense saying
that's illusory because the actual
fundamental degrees of freedom don't
fill out that much
they're not as numerous as that and
they're not as numerous as that
and if you right and if you try to
excite
more than a certain amount of structure
in that regional space
you will inevitably create a black hole
that's bigger than that region
and so there really is a limitation on
how much
how many bits of information you can
stuff into a region of space and it's
not the volume
that's the area so that's a that's a
that's a well accepted thing
the first person who
really got excited by this apart from
gerard and myself
and um who called me up wanted to know
more
class asked me please come to his
institution and talk about it
was in fact it it wouldn't edwin yeah he
got very excited by him
right yeah it's not his style it's not
his style of thing but you know
he's extraordinarily smart and he's a
great physicist and he saw he saw that
yeah but maybe that was right
yeah i mean in some sense this is
perhaps among the most radical breaks
with human intuition that have been
developed over the course of we're
talking evolution before
certainly evolution imprinted in us a
view of the world
yeah look at the world it's funny it's
so it's so widely accepted now that
nobody really seems to understand why or
why it was
considered so radical well that's always
what happened young young people here
yeah you know um so things go from a
crazy conjecture
to well crazy speculation
to a conjecture to a tool
of the trade in almost no time at all
and of course
you you of course know why it suddenly
became a tool of the trade it was the
work of one one
of the senior yeah when we get to that
so so so you are saying that even
in this room that i'm sitting or any
room that anybody else is sitting in
some sense
there is an illusion going on the
illusion that we have the freedom to
change things within this volume at will
is wrong the actual capacity of change
is far less and can be fully described
by
data that lives on a surface that
surrounds that region
yes that is what it says yeah so so it's
understandable that look i mean
obviously you always command a great
respect but i can imagine people hearing
that and saying
this is going one step too far and it
just doesn't seem like it could be right
yes and then as you say i'm sorry go
ahead
well i've always admired the the great
detective
sherlock um one of his uh i cannot i can
never quite remember the quote but uh
when you've what was it when you tried
everything
uh and everything doesn't work
that which is um may seem
most improbable but if it's all that's
left it has to be the truth
do you remember the quote it's a
sherlock holmes quote uh yeah i mean
the justification we've tried everything
and nothing works
uh nothing sensible works whatever's
left over
it must be the truth no matter how crazy
yeah have little doubt that somebody in
the chat will uh we'll give us
that quote in just just a moment uh but
so then
for the black hole story then you know
if i pull something out and i throw it
into a black hole
how would this description
assist us in dealing with the the
paradox the problem of
the information well the information was
ah okay so the way i thought about it at
the time which may have not been
i'm not sure it's exactly the right way
to think about the way that i thought
about it at the time
was the problem was that
information that falls into the black
hole cannot escape
because it can't exceed the speed of
light on the other hand
the hawking radiation must be carrying
off the information
and how did it escape from the black
hole well the intuition was that
really that it really was like a
hologram
that the stuff on the inside was to some
extent illusory as you say
i don't know if illusory is quite the
right term but
uh some sense a consequence of the
mathematics of the hologram
and that the reality is really stored on
the surface
just above the horizon of the black hole
and that eventually
the evaporation of the black hole was
tantamount to the evaporation of this
film of the uh
of the holographic film itself which
would
which contained all of the information
about what was inside the hologram
but when it's evaporated there's no
interior there's nothing left
because there's no image left in the
interior
because the hologram which was in some
sense the reality
has evaporated but the information was
not destroyed
it was carried off by the evaporation
products so that was
a little bit naive but that's the way i
thought about it at the time
and some of the things that you had to
contend with to make it less naive right
there was this issue that
i think you you and others raised that
you know you throw an encyclopedia in if
it if it goes in
and yet also leaves its information on
the surface
you seem to have these two copies of the
nation and there's this famous no
cloning
theorem in quantum mechanics that tells
you you can't actually
create those kinds of copies yeah so
that's right so i was uh that that was
right
the other person who thought about that
a lot was um
uh john pressgill and john preston
taught me classical mechanics when i was
an undergraduate
you know yeah right so yeah there was
this problem of the replication of
information
that in quantum mechanics the
replication of quantum information
is not permitted and so when something
falls into a black hole
according to the usual rules uh
it uh it can't be replicated in two
places at the same time
my answer to that at the time was by
thinking about various
duncan experiments i convinced myself i
think correctly
uh that it was absolutely impossible
for any actual observation or experiment
to see
both copies at the same time so it was
much like
um much like ordinary quantum mechanics
where you can
either describe a particle as having
a velocity or momentum or you can
describe it as having a position
but you can't describe it as having both
at once
i called it quant black hole
complementarity
that it was okay
to have this duplication of information
as long as nature itself
prevented any observation from
uh from seeing both replicas of the
information
and uh so through a series of arguments
i was able to convince myself and other
people
that it was impossible to have uh
knowledge of both what falls in
and what comes out if you're outside the
black hole you see what comes out
if you fall in with the material filling
you see it fall in you can't be both
outside and inside so it's really all
okay
i think it more or less worked out that
way and and so
taking that complementarity idea one
step
forward it raises the following question
so
many people who study black holes know
that
if you're looking at an object falling
in from the outside
something curious happens you see the
object getting closer and closer to the
horizon but you don't actually see it
falling over the edge
you see it redshifted you see it time
dilated and so forth but you never
actually see it crossover so in some
sense it gets plastered on the outside
yeah in retrospect would that have led
one
to think in the holographic idea i mean
was that part of your thinking that that
that got you there absolutely absolutely
that uh that was very much part of the
thinking
um i knew
actually i think from reading uh kip
thorne's book
on the membrane part kip thorne and
other people's
book on the membrane paradigm for black
holes yeah
membrane paradigm this was a technical
book this was not a
highly technical book more technical
than i wanted it to be
i had known about this picture that
everything that falls onto
a black hole forms a sort of sedimentary
structure that gradually sinks towards
the horizon but never passes it at least
that's the picture
that somebody watching it from the
outside says
and so from that picture i again there
was a sort of sherlock holmes moment
it has to be that way even though
in a frame of reference which is falling
with the material falling in it appears
to pass through the horizon
it still must be consistent to think
about it
as uh from the outside as having been
plastered
within let's say a plunk distance from
the horizon
so yes that was absolutely
an important part of it and yet the
thing that you that you mentioned in
there which is
among the things that makes it hard for
at least a general person to
fully understand this to the freely
falling individual
they pass through the horizon as if
there is nothing there
there's no impact at all but from the
outside
perspective there's a lot going on at
the horizon because all the stuff as you
say is getting plastered there and
ultimately
being emitted through the hawking
radiation
how about how do how to help someone put
these two perspectives together or do
you simply admonish them
using black hole complementarity and say
look take one perspective take the other
you're going to drive yourself crazy if
you try to think about them both at the
same time
right same kind of craziness you know a
particle what is a particle a particle
is a thing with a position
if it's anything at all it's a thing
with a position
if it has a position and every time it
has to have a velocity
so how do you reconcile in your head
that a particle has either a position or
a velocity or not
both and not both it's the same kind of
craziness
eventually you give up and you say those
are the rules of quantum mechanics you
uh you follow heisenberg
with his microscope trying to locate a
particle and both see its velocity in
his position his gadon
his thought microscope and what did you
discover
you discovered that whether or not you
think a particle has both a position and
a velocity you
simply cannot measure both so from an
operational point of view
there can't be a contradiction because
you cannot have access to both kinds of
information
that was my that was my opinion about
the black hole
problem that it was a problem of
complementarity and quantum mechanics
in which the two kinds of information
were incompatible no
experiment could could reveal
both what's going on as the material
fell
through the horizon and at the same time
watch from the outside i can't help but
ask though
so when we talk in quantum mechanics
about particles not having
a momentum and a position simultaneously
when i one always needs to ask myself
are we talking in terms of
the way reality is or the way reality is
measured
because for instance there is the de
bruy boom approach
to quantum mechanics i don't know if
this is an approach that has
excited you at all at times it has me
this is an approach
in which particles do have positions and
momentum simultaneously in terms of the
the properties that they actually have
the ontology the stuff that's real in
the world
even though as you say you can't measure
both but yet they do have
both whereas in conventional quantum
mechanics they really don't have
both simultaneously look at the wave
function it's either this wave function
or that wave function it can't be
eigen states if we use slightly
technical language of both the position
operating the momentum operator
would a de bruy boom like interpretation
have
any role in black hole complementarity
is there some sense that these things
are there
you just can't measure them you're not
talking about the particle now you're
talking about the information in the
black hole
yeah first of all i'm not a partisan of
the uh
the the broadly uh yeah most aren't yeah
no
no and if you ask me why i would say
well it's some kind of cooked up theory
of a single particle
but we live in a world of quantum fields
we live in a world of multi-particle
systems and
it gets so baroque and so complicated
when you try to
yeah think about quantum field theory in
that language that i
just don't think it goes anywheres yeah
i mean obviously there are people in
that community who have a different
perspective but that's another guy
i know and uh you know
who knows yeah look i am i'm a person
who knows how to use
i think i know how to use quantum
mechanics i know how to examine
experiments from the point of view of
quantum mechanics
am i puzzled about the whole quantum
mechanics
business of reality and non-reality
and uh and what the whole um
interpretation of quantum mechanics is
yes i am
but i think it was feynman who said it
best uh when he was asked about exactly
this he says i'm so puzzled about
quantum mechanics that i can't even tell
if there's a problem or not
yeah yeah no it's uh well i mean the
measurement problem seems like a
real issue that we have to resolve at
some point right we have an algorithm
without a mechanism
well i know i think there is a mechanism
i think the mechanism of entanglement
between the apparatus and the system
measured
is is a consistent
description of what happens during a
measurement the and do you take a mini
world's view
of things or i mean is it just the way i
wouldn't go that far
i wouldn't go that far i i find it just
very puzzling
okay you want me to tell you when i stop
thinking about this
where i tend to go yeah i wouldn't mind
all right yeah
um so imagine
this is where i start imagining i want
to make a model of the world
in which these kind of questions might
come up might even have answers so
take a giant tin can but tint can i just
mean
a volume of space let's forget the
holographic principle let's even forget
gravity or
quantum gravity and so forth we have a
volume of space which is isolated
closed volume of space and uh somebody
puts
a bunch of particles into it how many
particles oh i don't know 10 to the 50th
or maybe 10 to the 80th what is the
number of protons in the universe tend
to be into the 88 or
puts those particles into it uh
and allows it to evolve
okay it evolves quantum mechanically the
world's kind of rules are quantum
mechanics
and after having evolved for a while we
want to ask the question
um if
not if but is there an experiment
going on at coordinates x y z
in which an experiment is being done on
a single elementary particle
and what are the probabilities of the
result of that experiment
well if you start thinking if you start
thinking about that how you would
analyze that
you begin with the fact that the quantum
wave function the quantum state
of this collection of particles is
vastly big it has enormous amounts of
irrelevant information in it these are
the branches of the wave function
most of the wave function describes
things
or does not describe
a world in which there is even a planet
at your coordinates x y z
let alone an observer let alone an
observer doing a certain experiment
some tiny tiny portion of this wave
function
of this state vector or whatever we call
it
uh some tiny tiny tiny portion of it
buried in an enormous gigantic
branching tree of possibilities may
describe
the question that you're trying to
answer the uh
the whole quantum description is
excessive it has
much too much information in it and how
do you extract out anything
interesting from it it would be
absolutely impossible
to be compared with a classical
description in the classical description
there either is or is not an observer
doing a certain experiment someplace
sure because either
is that particles are in definite
locations
and you can simply go and see
whether there are particles forming an
observer
doing an experiment the quantum wave
function is vastly vastly bigger in
mathematical
complexity and because of that it
contains
information so big
that almost all of it would be relevant
to any experiment
okay then you could say well all right
look nevertheless i'm going to follow
that wave function
and what do we do with the wave function
we do experiments we do experiments and
use the wave function to get
probabilities
so what's an experiment the people
inside
this tin can if there are any people and
mostly there won't be people
uh they're not capable of doing an
experiment on themselves
we can imagine opening up the tin can
some observer who built the system can
then open the tin can look inside and do
an experiment
okay what you're going to find with
overwhelming probability he will just
find some totally
random mess of particles
it can measure the locations of the
particles or it can measure their
velocities you can't do both
and they'll just get a bunch of numbers
which has nothing to do
whatever with the questions you might
have wanted to ask about what's going on
in there
if you wanted to get better
information about probabilities you
could do it but you could only do it by
doing
many many many replicas of the same
experiment
but my point is here this is just
getting excessive it's getting out of
control
we don't know what the hell we're doing
we would not know how to use
even if somebody provided us with the
exact wave function we wouldn't know
what to do with it
so my feeling is at that level we really
don't understand quantum mechanics
but that's it that's a that's a really
important remark though
right because i think so if if for you
if we view quantum mechanics as the
fundamental
paradigm uh and we want you know it to
apply to everything
the stuff in the tin can the person from
the outside looking into the tin can
right um uh the the statement that
we don't know what to do with that
structure
is fundamentally pointing to a deep
ignorance
in in in the very basic laws of the
universe
right yeah yeah absolutely
you yeah um so my friend my friend
gerard
he believes he's ideas about this yeah
he's been he has ideas about it i don't
agree with the ideas i do again
again he's asking very very deep
questions
whether his answers are the right
answers i i of course don't know i don't
think i agree with them but uh
you know my feeling is anybody who takes
the time to sit down and think about
what quantum mechanics is and how it
relates to the world and so forth
can't help but uh have this sense of
confusion
the sense of right puzzlement
yeah i mean there's often there's often
the sense that einstein's resistance to
quantum mechanics was
a remnant of a dinosaur-like attitude
and it's not
no there's a real issue that
einstein many issues that is focused
upon and it's still with us
um so so with that i i you know you
mentioned juan
maldasena and the work that ultimately
brought the holographic principle this
idea that the information would be
stored on the surface to
its most refined form
that journey of course was the end point
of a journey that begins with other work
that you initiated which is string
theory
um so if we could just pivot for a
moment to string theory
don't forget don't forget our friend joe
polzinski
yeah absolutely but going further back
so
in the early days of string theory we're
now in the early
1970s um you know this
this this idea came along um
largely at first through the study of
interaction strong interaction physics
with
formulae that were written down that
seemed to do a good job of describing
certain kind of data
sets you looked at this mathematics and
within that
you saw the glimmers of string theory
so just just take us back to what that
was like
it's a long long time ago yeah
more than 50 years uh it was it was late
60s
1969 or 68 or 69
yeah um the questions and the physics
were not about gravity they were not
about gravitons
not even about photons they were about
hadrons
hadrons means subnuclear particles
protons neutrons
mesons the things which we now know are
made out of quarks uh
there was a lot of experimental data
about them
they were strongly interacting which
means when they collide they made lots
of junk and
all kinds of stuff but they also seemed
to have
a capacity that an electron for example
would not have
electron has spin okay but you can't
spin an electron like you can spin a
basketball
you can take a basketball you can still
can think of it as not
spinning or you can spin it up and you
can spin it up even faster
eventually of course if you spin it too
fast it'll break apart
but the basketball has all sorts of
rotational states
uh an electron has only
one or one or two states of existence
it's its rotational properties
hadrons seem to be more in a certain
sense like basketballs
you could rotate them up and uh
the proton could be spun up so that at a
higher angular momentum
whole sequences of states
of higher and higher spin seemed
to grow out of spinning up a proton
so uh that was that had nothing to do
with me that was experimental physics
from the 60s
a physicist a very good physicist by
the name of gabriele veneziano
who i didn't know at the time had
constructed a formula
for the scattering of hatrons
and it had embedded in it all this
information
about the possibility of spinning up
the particles which collided and it was
called the veneziano formula
i'm sure that you know what it is here
but
right uh and it was a very simple
formula
it it what did it describe it to
describe the amplitude or the
probabilities
for the scattering of two particles to
result in different outcomes
it was just a function of two variables
a variable called s
in a variable called t it doesn't matter
the momentum of the particles
it was very simple it had a product of
two functions two well-known
common garden varieties oh let's tell
people there were gamma functions we can
they were gamma functions right a gamma
function two gamma functions in the
numerator and one gamma function of the
denominator and that's all that it was
okay
so somebody came and showed me that that
formula
and the thing that struck me was not all
the physics that went into it but the
simplicity of it
and i noticed that it did have this
structure that described let's call them
the excited states of the particles that
were colliding
or the excited states of the particles
that could occur
in the intermediate states of the
collision
and the other thing that i noticed is
that those excited states in their
energy were equally spaced
they looked like harmonic oscillators
they have the spectrum of energies of a
harmonic oscillator or equally spaced
energy levels
true enough the equal spacing was in the
mass squared
not in the mass but never mind that it
was a detail
and so i looked at this thing and i said
my goodness this
must be some kind of harmonic oscillator
and so i started experimenting around i
i knew
a lot about
harmonic oscillators one of the few
things i knew about
and so i made a model the model was a
harmonic oscillator which meant
two particles connected by a spring
and a third particle a photon would
scatter off
one of the particles in the spring you
could think of the two particles as
being charged particles
and the charged particles would scatter
a photon
the photon would be absorbed and
re-emitted
by the charged particle and i worked out
the corresponding amplitude for that and
it looked an awful much
like the veneziano amplitude not quite
not quite it looked enough like it that
that i wrote a little paper called the
harmonic oscillator analogy for the
viniciano amplitude
and it was during that period when i was
writing the paper that i
realized i i knew that it wasn't quite
right i knew it was just an analogy
that i realized that if you added more
oscillators and
turned the spring into a string i called
it a rubber band at that time
that you would get exactly the minutiano
amplitude
right that was exciting i mean it was uh
something uh
i don't know how to describe the feeling
that you get when you when you encounter
a thing like that
uh so it worked i knew at that point
exactly that
that what this thing was
and i was pretty certain that hadrons
really worked that way
it was kind of interesting the
psychology of it i was very excited
because i thought i was the only one in
the world who knew that
yeah when you think you're the only one
in the world who knows something and
you're about to tell everybody it
and we think okay that's that's uh
something exciting yeah
what i didn't count on is that there was
somebody else who knew exactly the same
thing
exactly bamboo
[Music]
bamboo of course was a great physicist
at that time he was
uh one of my heroes so on the one hand i
was terribly disappointed to find out
that somebody else knew it on the other
hand if it had to be somebody else
better that it was nambu i felt a
certain exhilaration
in having discovered something that the
great mambo had discovered
and when you wrote that those paper they
weren't exactly
met with standing ovation right no they
were
they were rejected by the physical
review letters yeah and so i mean was
that
it was that a sense of terrible
objection or
yeah or did you just say that those are
silly people and they don't just get it
you know oh i said both i've been
rejected by silly people
who just don't get it right right now
somebody wrote
somebody wrote a referee's report saying
uh
there there's no new information no new
experimental
data in this paper and there are other
derivations of the veneziano model
so i don't recommend publication of it
and yes indeed i was very hurt and
i was not a famous physicist at that
time
but you resubmitted someplace else
presumably and uh
it was yeah i did resubmit the physical
review it was published
yeah uh but it took a long time and
during that long time
i was um right not happy
by 1984 so i was a graduate student i
started graduate school in 1984
and um you know by that time
string theory had just bubbled up to the
surface where
there was a basic feeling that if you
weren't doing string theory
you were missing the boat and it was the
most i mean for me was it
you know if i look back on my years the
most exciting period there because
all of these greats in physics were
buzzing around
saying here it is you know this is the
thing that we have been
looking for at that time did you think
that the pendulum had swung too far the
other
way you know from you know initial
rejection that was wrong but
was it you know i guess uh greenspan's
you know
uh you know uh whatever the word was you
know euphoria that wasn't
you know justified by where we were
no i i i didn't feel that
um i did feel that it wasn't addressing
this one question which i thought was
so central the question of the black
holes and then
until it did that uh that it had to be
considered
um well what we would call perturbation
theory
i didn't think it got to the true depths
of the
uh very very hard problems about quantum
gravity
but i i think i along with a lot of
other people thought that there was a
reasonable hope
that some version of it not the precise
versions that people were working with i
knew that they couldn't work they were
too super symmetric
they were too special but i did think
that there was
a good hope that some particular version
of it
would um nail the particle physics uh
spectrum that would explain the three
generations of uh you know the three
families of quarks the
electron and neutrino all that sort of
stuff or at least
be able to accommodate those particles
some particular
version some particular what we call a
compactification which you know very
well
some collabo manifold or something which
i still know very little about
that that would nail apart you want to
know i'm happy to have a
yeah right you said you certainly can um
but you know after a period of trying
and uh
and particularly a number of things
dissuaded me from that the things which
dissuaded me from it were cosmological
the cosmological constant well lack of
supersymmetry in the world
um the cosmological constant the
uh the successive inflation
and all those things together with an
observation that i think was
joe polczynski and raphael busso
that who estimated the number of
possible
solutions of string theory that by that
i mean the number of
possible string theories that you could
have and that was
gigantic they said 10 to the 500 the
number may be
vastly bigger than that and
so it came down then to
saying we have a theory which has so
many possibilities
that looking for the right one would be
like a needle in the haystack
and or a word much much worse than a
needle in a haystack
and uh so i began to feel
that the that the effort to find
a precise version of string theory which
would describe particle physics
was probably misguided maybe buried in
this huge heap of possibilities
there was something but how do we make a
theory
instead of finding the right precise one
how do we make a theory or something
useful
about this observation that there are 10
to the 500 possibilities
yeah and that
for a period i think that led me um
to be a bit of a pariah in the string
theory community
they didn't want to hear that yeah now i
remember you and i talking about this i
think was in sweden or something at some
gathering
and i asked you remember i asked you do
you really believe this are you just
trying to stir
up the other stranger you know
i'm not a star yeah you know it's
definitely definitely genuine so we'll
come to
you know the development that ultimately
yields uh the holographic
refinement if you will but um let's go
back to string theory for a minute yeah
please yeah
yeah i i think string theory has had a
gigantic success
but the success is not was not in
reproducing the particle spectrum
and that sort of thing it was providing
a an example an existence
example uh for
a theory which allowed quantum mechanics
and gravity to be combined
consistently yeah and that's no
small thing that
it i'm not talking about the early
versions of string theory i'm talking
about the later things things like
matrix theory and ads cft
and all these things that juan invented
and so forth
which produced a very a series of very
very precise
and exact let me call them universes
uh in which quantum mechanics black
holes
and gravity coexisted consistently
so after that happened
if somebody came and told you look
there's a contradiction between quantum
mechanics and gravity
was a contradiction between black holes
and standard predictions of gravity you
could say no
there is no such contradiction we know
that because we have an extremely
precise set of examples
and i consider that to be you know a
great
triumph of string theory yeah no i fully
agree
and i'm glad you raised that point
because i think as as
you know i know and as many people
watching this know
there's a lot of chatter out there a lot
of nonsensical chatter
out there which tries to make the case
that
string theory is useless it's collapsed
it's gone away something's wrong with
the theory
and and and the point that you're making
of course is the right one which is sure
there are many unresolved issues about
connecting string theory to the real
world
but to show that gravity and quantum
mechanics can coexist
in a coherent consistent manner a
mathematically calculable matter a
precise mathematically calculated manner
that justifies the existence of string
theory and all the work that's being
done to develop it forward
and it's just really sad when i see
people get the wrong impression
from the blogs and the books and things
that
that are out there it used to be in the
old days the physicists would do their
work and nobody paid any attention and
it was great
now everybody pays attention and
everybody has an opinion and everybody
gets extremely contentious and political
and all that kind of crap and uh
yeah it's not nice yeah no
exactly so uh a breath of fresh air for
the the actual situation to be more
accurately described
um but um
let's now turn to the work that
was spearheaded initially by joe
polczynski and
ultimately results in the achievement of
juan maldasena which comes through
the technology of string theory and
ultimately connects with the earlier
part of our discussion
which is this holographic idea it's a
tough subject to discuss but
can you give a brief summary of what
juan found
yeah um let me first say
something about both these two people
and more than these two people are
currently evolving generation
we tend to think of the generation of
einstein and heisenberg and schroedinger
something extraordinary exceptional that
never happened again in physics
i don't think that's true i think people
like juan
and joe ochinski and alda cena and the
and also the great string theorists
were every bit i don't know about
einstein einstein was a very special
case but they're every bit
this uh the uh the equals of the people
in the early part of the 20th century
who invented quantum mechanics and so
forth
i'm just saying that because i want
people to know that
that the heroic age of physics
has not passed uh completely
okay now you asked me about what juan
did and what joe did
yep so
it when i say it it will sound like it's
not
as much as it really was it's hard to
it's hard to explain how something could
be so important
and at the same time be very simple
but let me just say it was extremely
important joel
invented or discovered that in string
theory
there were contained uh a set of objects
they're called d
brains they were not the strings of
string theory
but they were sets of objects planes or
lines or even
points which were more massive than
strings
but strings could simply end on them so
they were like let's see if we can make
an
analogy um
imagine a wire kind of thing yeah yeah
yeah
right beads on a wire that kind of thing
except the strings could be attached to
those beads
okay there were new structures and
string theory that were
that nobody knew about nobody realized
they were there
a whole new set of objects they were
heavier and they were called
d brains joe worked out the theory of
those
and sort of startled i i would say
certainly startled me
yeah the one person who i think
everybody was startled
i think edwin was sort of close may have
been close to some of these ideas
uh and um
so there's no object existed
there's no objects existed and there's
no objects which existed let's say there
were exa
examples of three brain three brains
three brains would have three dimensions
uh
two brains would be like membranes
the structures these structures
could have objects on them living on
them like you said
beads the theory of those objects that
lived on them
was actually quantum field theory itself
quantum fields
living on these d brains these quantum
fields
were all right it doesn't matter what
they were but what
what juan realized is that these
structures these brains these surfaces
had all of the ingredients that were
necessary for them to be
the holograms of the holographic
principle
[Music]
and he basically worked that out a
very very precise and exact version
of the holographic principle
in which the hologram itself that means
the film was replaced
by a d brains
collection of these d brains and
that uh the image
of this hologram
was like the actual reality described by
string theory
so to put it short it was
a very precise instantiation
of the holographic principle
and uh it was
revolutionary it was shocking and it
came directly out of joe's uh
joe pochinski's construction of the d
brains
but it has truly revolutionized this
area of physics
yeah and with this new
holographic construction
which did not rely on perturbation
theory it didn't rely on recoupling
and so forth it provided worlds that we
could study
in which quantum mechanics and gravity
we knew
very very precisely that uh
that they were consistent that they
contained black holes
and so that uh that that very much
revolutionized the subject
and shortly thereafter so ed edwin
writes a paper where he shows if you
have a black hole
in the bulk the volume if you will
the holographic description is just hot
quantum field theory which
has no issue with the unitarity that you
and
gerard have been arguing for that's
correct yeah and and that basically
at least in an abstract level nails the
case
that the information has got got to come
out
how did the community also wrote a paper
together it's the only paper i ever
wrote with that in which we
connected the ideas of the deep brains
with the holographic principle
right and so at that point
was there still any resistance from the
hawking
general relativity or was that basically
it
um you know it was
well i was going to say something i
would probably regret saying
we can always cut it out of the one we
post if you want to try it all right
that was i was going to say it was like
trump uh
trump refusing to admit that he lost the
election hey don't regret but of course
of course there was no similarity
whatever between stephen walking and the
dominant oh yeah the stephen hawking
were lit yeah i see that analogy would
have some issues yeah
yeah that has some trouble with it but i
don't mind if you say it but let me just
make perfectly clear and plain
stephen was a hero and a hero and a hero
and that's it right
but uh yeah there was it it did have
that sense that people were fighting a
dying battle
that uh there was no point in even
fighting it anymore it was finished
right um so within some period of time
that issue was was laid to rest
um but it's still but but it's not as
though that story is over
right i mean so once you know that the
information comes out of a black hole by
virtue of
translating the question into this
holographic
question where the answer is manifest
obvious that there's no loss of
information
there's still the issue of the details
of how the information
gets out and so for instance joe
polczynski who you mentioned before
together with three collaborators writes
a paper
that raises some tension some issues in
trying to think about how the
information
comes out suggesting possibility that
there's a firewall at the edge of a
black hole and so forth was that it
was not a surprising paper was that one
of those papers
very and for a while i was
i i wasn't sure if they were right or
not but um
it was very disconcerting
what uh yeah well joe
don maroff and two students
at the time one uh i've met mary and the
other
james sully uh wrote a paper
in which saying it was logically
impossible
that after a certain period of an
evaporating black hole
back oil is evaporating after it has
evaporated
half of its not its energy but half of
its entropy
that it was simply logically impossible
for the black hole to have a smooth
horizon
a horizon that you could fall through in
other words all the features that we
thought were true of horizons of black
holes it was
and they even said that it was logically
impossible for this black hole
complementarity idea to be correct
right uh the argument was
very convincing it made use of quantum
entanglement
uh it was a simple argument it said
on the one hand it said that the
consistency of
the horizon required that the interior
of the black hole and the exterior of
the black hole be entangled
quantum mechanically entangled on the
other hand it said
that the radiation which is carried off
by the hawking radiation
will necessarily be entangled with a
black hole
and the third element is a thing cannot
be entangled simultaneously with two
other things
maximum can't have right you can't have
the outside of the black hole being
tangled with the radiation
and at the same time with the interior
of the black hole and so something has
to give
and their conclusion was that what gave
was that the horizon of the black hole
has to become an impenetrable barrier
so that in effect the black hole doesn't
have an interior
um this did you lose sleep on that one i
mean
like yeah i totally guess i lost sleep
on that one um
yes very much so and
to my mind at first i was convinced they
might be right
uh that old black holes would have this
problem
i i didn't think so after a while i just
thought no this is much like the hawking
thing this is a great question it's a
deep question very very fundamental
i suspect they've taken the easy answer
and that the hard answer is the one
which will
allow these two things to coexist at the
same time
the smoothness of the horizon and the
entanglement structure
so uh and
the answer to that i think is the answer
that
what's called now e r equals epr
juan and i started to discuss this over
email it's the only
it's the only time i've ever
collaborated successfully over email
was with maldasena um
i just sent him a message at some point
and said one this is crazy there's
something wrong with us
can we try to figure out what's wrong
with it and
we batted ideas back and forth oh for at
least
a month maybe for more than a month
daily emails
i could never get him to answer me on
sunday but uh he was with his family on
sunday but
for six days a week we batted back and
forth
ideas um
and we have both been perturbed by one
particular thing
that there was a particular construction
it was one of juan maldasena's early
constructions it was called the eternal
black hole
which was really two black holes two
entangled black holes
and it seemed to violate
what joe and company had said
the black hole on one side was
completely entangled with a black hole
on the other side and yet it didn't seem
to have this trouble
that they claimed would be there if the
black hole was entangled with anything
else
and so both of us had been troubled by
that and at some point
juan sent me a very cryptic message
it was about the things we were talking
about but i think it had one
it was a very short message and it said
er
equals epr and when i saw that i said
holy smoke that
is what's going on and what
i'm sure you want to get to that so i'll
let you ask the questions you want to
ask
well you know it's it's a it's a
beautiful and and
and deep result uh maybe just for the
audience we have the uh a little picture
of the epr
paper we can bring that up just to show
people so it's 1935
einstein padolsky and rosen write this
paper about quantum entanglement that
distant particles can be somehow
connected by some threads of of quantum
entanglement
and then the er you're referring to just
for the audience uh
is another paper uh that einstein writes
with rosen podolski got kicked off or
something i don't know where podolski
was and that one that had to do with
uh wormholes now now i believe it's the
case
that nobody thought there was any
einstein
didn't think there's any connection
between these two 1935 papers they were
just different
yeah i i don't believe he had any
inkling whatever if he did he was even
smarter than einstein
yeah yeah because
once in the realm of quantum mechanics
the others in the realm of general
relativity um and and then
in essence what the email that you're
referring to that juan
sent you was saying hang on these two
papers there is
a deep connection between well they're
the same thing
same thing yeah um
talking about i mean it wasn't that we
weren't with that we hadn't been
yeah talking about very closely related
things
uh but you said this in such a succinct
way when i saw that i said that has to
be true
yeah that has to be true and so i very
quickly put the story together
and i wrote it up one rewrote it i
rewrote it and um
and uh there's this but this was another
very crazy idea
that um another
with another sherlock holmesian story to
it that has to be true because nothing
else can possibly be true
so the idea you know
entanglement is a connection between
potentially distant systems which um
has a certain quantum mechanical
connectivity
to these systems wormholes is a
connection
between possibly distant systems they
can have wormholes connecting them
distant black holes
we went through all the properties of
entanglement
in particular for example the idea that
you can't send a message
from one place to another using
entanglement
even though it's you know people always
think you can send messages
yeah faster than lighter you can't you
can't exceed the speed of light and if
you look at it from the entanglement
point of view
there's a there's a reason why and
wormholes
something similar that uh wormholes
connecting two distant places you would
think you could send a signal through
in both cases you get frustrated by
different things
in one case it's by the properties of
quantum mechanics and the other it's by
the properties of general relativity
and a whole set of things about
entanglement
seem to be parallel to the things about
wormholes
juan's message was just a uh capping the
story off and the
with the clever er equals cpr uh phrase
because he had been thinking about these
things for a long time this was not
totally new to him
um it hit me very suddenly i mean very
quickly i knew that this was the answer
to the amps
of the um the firewall paradox
and um so you can playing to us how it
answers it i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah um
what's behind how do you describe the
things which are behind the horizon of a
black hole
just behind the horizon of a black hole
well
whatever they are they are things which
are quantum mechanically entangled
with the degrees of freedom just in
front of the horizon
uh you know the story the story is you
understand the evaporation of black
holes
is by pairs being produced pairs of
particles one foot one of negative
energy falls into the black hole
one of positive energy goes flying off
and forms a hawking radiation
and those two particles are entangled
so it is important
that the interior and the exterior of
the black hole be
entangled on the other hand
after the radiation has been thoroughly
uh
half the radiation has gone out the
black hole is entangled with its own
radiation
and presumably it can't be entangled
with both
okay so let's see where was i good
one resolution of the paradox
is that the things behind the horizon of
the black hole
are actually the same as
the things in the outgoing radiation
that was just behind the horizon of the
black hole is
nothing but or the information content
is the same as the information content
of the outgoing
radiation well how can that be the
outgoing radiation is very far away
the interior of the black hole is close
by how can they be the same thing
and the answer is they can only be the
same thing if there's a secret
passageway between the distant talking
radiation
and the black hole and that's what we
call the einstein-rosen bridge
if the outgoing radiation could be
thought of as another system
connected by entanglement to the black
hole
then there could be this kind of tunnel
or wormhole between them
so that the outgoing radiation would
basically be in some sense
also behind the horizon of the black
hole right
and that that it's it's it's i can't do
it i can't do a decent job on this
without a piece of paper and a pencil
and some equations
sure but that's the way the thing went
and um
it was it was fairly convincing to
people er equals epr was kind of was
accepted
pretty quickly by this community but in
the very recent past um
a whole gang of very young people
well al mary himself who was ahmed was
one of the
people on the firewall paper jeff
pennington
other people very very young not much
more than students in fact jeff was a
student
really sort of nailed this idea
that the that the outgoing distant
hawking radiation
is really the same as the interior of
the black hole
they have done for that idea what
maldasena himself did for the um
for the uh holographic idea
nailed it in place with a very very
sharp new version of it
which you know it's too hard to explain
yeah no it's beautiful work it is it is
complex but just for an overarching idea
you know when we think about
the other forces not gravity nuclear
forces electromagnetic force we of
course have a well-defined
quantization procedure whereby we take
the classical
articulation of these forces and we
bring them into the quantum world
right gravity seems to i mean through er
equals epr in some sense the statement
is gravity knows
classical gravity knows about quantum
mechanics at some
level it's it's somehow different in in
that way so
what what's the lesson there is is is
gravity smarter than we thought it was
and that it already and or quantum
mechanics or
quantum mechanics are smaller than the
other way yeah that's right um
yeah no i make this point repeatedly
that like i sometimes call it gr
equals qm i got i got memory of this
kind of uh
these little equals yeah yeah
uh what yeah okay so
you asked me about quantization of
gravity
let me just let me just uh explain what
that means
as you said there's a set of rules for
taking classical systems
harmonic oscillator an atom or a
orbiting system and converting it to
quantum mechanics
the rules were invented primarily by
dirac in 1990 around 1930
and um we've learned
that that's the way you take a a
theory and convert it to a quantum
theory they work for electrodynamics
it works for yang mills theory it works
for the standard model and so forth and
so on
it even works for string theory uh
not not in quite the same way
it never worked for gravity anytime
anybody tried it it always led to
disaster
various kinds of disasters black holes
were one of them
infinities or another it never worked
and i think what we're learning now is
that gravity and quantum mechanics are
too
closely connected to pull them apart
and then put them back together again by
quantity by quantization
by the rules of quantization um
that they're just it's not that they
it's not that they're inconsistent with
each other they're too
close they are too much the same thing
to pull them apart and then quantize
what you've pulled apart
and go back so er equals epr as an
example there's a whole bunch of
examples now
of basic quantum phenomena
which are very generic quantum phenomena
which
reappear in another guys through the
holographic principle
which appear reappear in other guys as
gravitational phenomena
i won't go through them but they are
like er equals epr
two a basic quantum mechanical thing
on one side a basic gravitational thing
on the other side
and finding out that they are in some
sense equivalent or very parallel to
each other
so i don't think we've put the whole
thing together yet i don't think we have
a complete story about how these things
fit together
it's getting more complete but but we
don't have a complete story
but i think the evidence is kind of
leaning in the direction
that gravity is not something to
quantize it's already quantized it just
doesn't makes it it is quantum mechanics
the two go together hand and fist uh and
are too close to
to separate that's my view that's my
view
um what do you think it means for the
future of of space time say i mean space
time is always something that we sort of
put in
from the get-go in our theories will it
be the case as many of us have suspected
that
space-time is just some emergent thing
that
arises in certain environments but is
not a fundamental
ingredient to build your theory out of i
think that could be
that could be what it's telling us
[Music]
a bunch of quantum mechanical degrees of
freedom where the right kind of
entanglement structure
can emerge as a space time
and uh just a whole bunch of qubits you
know quantum mechanical bits
linked together by the right kind of
entanglement quantum entanglement
structure
can have the properties of space-time
that's one direction that seems um
a possible direction but you know i've
learned not to try to predict too far in
the future
uh surprises happen it's the rule that
surprises happen the only thing about
surprise is that
it's not surprising that surprises
happen it's just that whenever they
happen they're very surprising
now it'd be very surprising if there
were no surprises
yeah generally when you have a good set
of ideas
the surprises don't reverse the
direction
of uh that you're going in
but they can make it bend off at an
angle yeah
and so i sort of learned not to try to
get ahead of myself
and to try to guess what uh where
things are going because
i'll usually be 50 right and 50 wrong
and i can't guess which part is right
which is wrong you know let me ask you
one final final thing you've been very
generous
with your time lenny i appreciate that
um
i'm often asked uh where
based on what you anticipated
say in the 1980s are we further ahead
than
where you thought we'd be are we not as
far ahead
uh can you sort of grade how well we as
a community
have done if you look back 30 40 years
what's your view on that well these
these uh these uh
things which are just one step ahead of
the monkeys have followed the dot dots
in a way that i could not have imagined
it's been a collective effort there's
been a few people who've really stood
out
uh i think i won't mention names right
now a few people have really stood out
but it has been a collective effort and
um it i i'm just
blown away and amazed by how far we have
gotten
in understanding these questions i
didn't no i did not i i also thought
like feynman that would be 500 years
before we'd really have answers to them
yeah that 500 years has turned out to be
what 25 30
so something like that yeah
it's spectacular absolutely i i find it
very spectacular
and as i said to my mind it means
that the heroic age of physics
uh has not gone away
yeah yeah i totally agree so
again thanks so much for joining us and
by the way if you ever
like in the beaver kill or want to come
to the beaver first
i'll remember that revisit your fly
fishing days uh
i don't i don't have my fly rod anymore
yeah i'm sure we can
i'm sure we can arrange something
anything have you ever tried it
i've never tried fly fishing you know
i'm vegan so somehow there's part of me
that doesn't want to do that
can you catch and release yeah but you
can just think you can just take the
hook
off the fly yeah and just cast the flies
that's very relaxing hey that's get your
waders and go out into the paper kill
and uh just take the hook off the fly
you have to
you know it's a little cold right now as
you can see outside we got about three
feet of snow behind me oh
beautiful beautiful but when uh when it
warms up yeah you gotta wait for what
you can't get a license until uh
you know fishing license until about
april i forget oh i didn't know that
okay again
obviously i'm an amateur yeah you get
arrested
is that true wow all right well i'll
keep all that in mind
with the advice as well uh so thanks and
look i look forward to
seeing you at some point when this
endemic thing uh
is over but thanks for joining us here
everybody thank you very much
thank you bye-bye bye
all right everybody that was a real fun
conversation with uh
lenny susskind we covered a lot of
ground it's uh
it's three o'clock i'm pretty tired guys
um let me just see if there any
questions in the chat that i might
address before we call it a day here
um yeah many people are uh
thanking lenny for joining us and i
thank you guys for thanking him
um let us see
uh any final questions before we uh
we wrap it up
um someone asked can we cite the work
that was mentioned
um there's not one particular paper that
really
sums up everything that we spoke about
certainly if you want to know the story
of the
of the black hole war up to the early
years
of 2000s i know maybe 2005 2006 you
should check out lenny's book
uh the black hole war you know you
should buy copies for all your friends
it's christmas time it's a great gift
that's a
a wonderful read that goes through the
journey in much more detail than we did
here today of
the information paradox and hawking's
realizations
and beckenstein's insights and
ultimately all the way through
the holographic ideas of suskind and a
tuft
as well as juan maul the cena's you know
incredible breakthrough in the mid-1990s
where string theory gave as lenny
described this concrete realization this
concrete instantiation
of the holographic idea so that's a
great
that's a great resource to take a look
at
and beyond that it's mostly the research
literature there's not a whole
lot else really to look at at the moment
um somebody's asking uh simon anthony is
asking would roger penrose
agree with what we discussed here today
and some of it he would certainly agree
with
some of it i think he'd be quite
skeptical about as you heard
you know i think penrose has a visceral
reaction against string theoretic ideas
and just think they're the wrong
direction
so i presume he would
consider any insights that emerge from
tools
that have been developed by string
theory he would be suspicious
of those conclusions but you know the
point that lenny is making
it's a point that i've made a lot too
but it's it's just great to hear it from
different people even if string theory
is not the right theory of the world the
fact that
we were able to write down a
mathematical system
that puts together gravity and quantum
mechanics in a
systematic coherent sensible
logical paradox-free manner
that's powerful because if
for instance if hawking was right
his initial view i mean hawking changed
his mind toward the end
of his life and actually did come on
board and did take on this perspective
that the information is not lost so
the the analogy and already lenny
disavowed it so
this shouldn't be taken any personally
but the analogy with like
trump resisting the election uh hawking
absolutely came around to this
perspective but his earlier
view that the information would be lost
were that to be true
that argument was so general the one
that he made
that it should apply to any theory that
successfully puts gravity and quantum
mechanics together therefore it should
apply
to the string theoretic description of
black holes and the fact that it doesn't
even if string through is not the right
theory of the world that
shows there's a deep issue a problem
with hawking's argument and indeed there
is a
problem with hawking's argument you need
to include
all these other features of gravity
and quantum mechanics that we discussed
here today
that have been developed by many people
the late joe
polczynski brilliant physicist who
tragically sadly died not too long ago
a young man uh and and the great work of
juan maldisan and many others
including the young physicist that lenny
was mentioning
so would would roger disagree sure
but i don't think he would disagree with
the logical links
as being described whether or not string
theory is the right theory the world the
logical links
are the ones that allow you to conclude
that hawking's initial
proposal that the information was lost
could not
be correct okay anything else
before we uh wrap it up um
no i think we're good okay so
again as you see we listened to the
suggestions you make a number of people
had
suggested that we speak with uh lenny
susscon i wanted to do that anyway so
it's always nice
when there's consonants between the
direction that
we are headed in this series that we've
been having and the
people you'd like us to bring on feel
free to make more suggestions
we'd love to hear where you would like
these conversations to go
with topics people and we will likely do
another one of these
in probably two weeks we've been sort of
getting into that rhythm
once every two weeks but maybe we'll do
one before then
my teaching at columbia has just wrapped
up which gives me a little bit
more time to think about things of this
sort i should also mention
that the epr and the er
papers that we made reference to it
turns out that we're
since those are 1935 we're in the 85th
anniversary of both of those
papers and in celebration of that and in
celebration of this unexpected link
between these ideas
we are going to have a world science
festival program
that is going to explore the connection
between
entanglement and wormholes i don't know
exactly when that's going to be
available
we're in the process of putting that
program together but just so you know
for those of you who want to hear more
about this and hear other voices
weigh in on the subject this will be one
of our
world science festival programs in the
not too distant future
so if you want to know about that you
should
follow me on twitter i'm going to be
announcing as these programs become
available that's at begreen
at twitter you should follow world
science festival i don't know what your
screen looks like right now but
somewhere on your screen i think there's
a button
where you can follow world science
festival both in terms of youtube or the
social channels
twitter or facebook as well
okay that then wraps us up here for
today
thanks for joining us and i look forward
to
carrying on these uh conversations in
the not too distant future
okay brian green signing off bye
[Music]
you